who do you think would win with uh Tommy
Fury versus Jake Paul if they fought
today you see that's a hard one now
because that's what we're out God yeah I
Gotta Give the props to uh to Paul right
Jake Paul he he really I start really to
like this guy and the reason I like him
is because the speech that he made after
the time remotely knock out he started
talking about listen guys he grabbed the
microphone and uh you know I never
understand I was a bully but I realized
now because I started boxing and I did
so many it's training is so hard I take
it to the next level you know I realized
I was an [ __ ] I was a bully and you
know and now it stops and I'm now I want
to be positive to the people and I go
wow when you see him running and he's
doing everything you know and BJ Flores
is his coach it's a friend of mine uh
and but he's everything that he says he
was going to do he's doing I mean
Anderson Silva and I go if everybody was
and I was thinking too Anderson was
going to win this fight but still he
beat him you know yes he's older but he
beat him you know so you got to give
props to a guy like that